Hello, everybody.
Oh, my God, I'm so tired.
I'm so tired.
Hello, everyone.
After the concert today, I went straight through nap time.
So, I'll talk more about the concert itself later today.
Later, later.
You don't sound... Oh, it's because I'm so... I literally just woke up and I'm, like, extra E.P.
I didn't really have a lot of sleep today because I had to, like, make sure everything was going smoothly.
And because of that, I didn't get to sleep much until after the concert.
But I'll talk more in depth about the concert later tonight because today is Marvel Rivals time!
Because, yes, surprise Rivals stream because I have the early season previews, early season access.
So, hey, guys.
Thank you for the outcome.
Super.
Thank you.
Since it's already on the 4th, I'm on my end.
I'm totally not looking for excuses.
Throw money at you.
Happy birthday, my Kamiyoshi!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, Dookie Bird!
Happy birthday to you.
Yeah!
Thank you, guys!
Yes, tomorrow is my birthday.
Yay!
And tonight we're having a little countdown!
Wow!
Yes, so... Oh, yeah, by the way, I was late because...
I was...
The download for the early access literally opens...
Okay, sorry.
I didn't go to sleep straight away.
I had to, like...
I took a one hour...
I think I took, like, a 40 minute...
A 30 minute nap.
Because I had to download the files for Marvel Rivals...
At exactly...
I think it was, like, 4 p.m.
Yes, at 4 p.m.
The download link shows up for everybody.
For those who get early access.
And then, so I wake up and then I downloaded the file.
And then I had...
I set my alarm to 4.30.
Because it takes 4...
It takes, like, 30 minutes...
To download the file.
And then I had to extract the...
So then I set it to 30 minutes.
And then...
But then I realized, oh, it's taking a while.
So...
It took a while to...
Open the link to download the game.
So...
Because, like, everybody was clicking it.
So I waited until, like...
So the file didn't download until...
4...
Like, 4.15.
And then, um...
I down...
It was downloading at 4.15.
And then I took another 30-minute nap.
Uh...
Because after I downloaded it, I have to...
Extract the files.
And that's another 30 minutes.
So...
That's why we're a little late.
Because after I finished that...
I woke up again.
And I was like, oh, fuck it now.
I need to extract the file.
And then I...
Went to extract the file.
And I was like, okay, we're not gonna make it.
I need to push the stream time.
I need to push the stream time a little bit.
And then I took another 30-minute nap.
And then now I'm here.
But the game is finally finished downloading.
So we can finally play the game.
I won't go too much detail about Life Update or the concert today.
Because I'm gonna save all of that for tonight slash tomorrow.
So let's just go right into it.
So, um...
Yes.
Surprise Rival Stream.
Because I forgot that...
I've been so busy...
That I forgot about, like, the new season.
And didn't realize the early season previews were actually today.
But actually this week.
Because, you know, I've been prepping for my concert.
And my birthday for the last month.
So, I haven't really been doing much.
Uh, in terms of, like, um...
Other, like, you know...
I haven't been, like, really been paying too much attention to, like, the competitive side of my revivals.
Or just, like, you know, playing my revivals in general.
Just because I've been just so swamped with everything.
Um, but I was like, you know, fuck it, you know.
I need to...
I...
I need to take advantage of everything I can stream right now to pay off my debt.
I don't have any debts.
But...
I will reveal how much it costs later tonight for the concert.
Because at least...
It was nice to know that the general reception for the concert was really good.
So, I will let you guys know how much it costs in the end.
I'll let you guys in the VTuber secrets of, like, how much these things fucking cost.
So, I was like, I gotta stream as much as I can.
I need to make up for all that money I spent on not only producing the 3D concert, but also, like, you know, like, the mixing and everything as well.
So...
You know, I was...
Oh, my God.
Okay.
And then, apparently...
I don't remember if I told this in the member stream or if I said this in the member stream or if I said this, like, in the public stream.
But I was exchanging notes with another friend that has, like, has done, like, 3D concerts.
And, um, she was telling me, like, bro, that's pretty cheap.
Because, um, because I went with a Chinese studio for my 3D concert.
And my friend was, like, uh, who knows, like, JP concert prices was, like, bro, that's pretty cheap.
Because sometimes they charge double that.
And I was, like, no fucking way.
I was, like, no fucking way.
Because my concert looked really good for...
For them telling me that that's pretty, like, that's, like, the cheap end.
Oh, Kiko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, Doki Brewed, happy birthday.
It's my birthday, too.
Happy to see the Sloppy Squad at the concert.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Kiko.
Yeah, happy birthday.
Thank you again.
I really appreciate it.
All right.
Let me just boot up this game real fast.
Before we...
Oh, yeah.
By the way, I forgot to mention, for those who don't know about the new season change...
I won't be streaming too long.
I'll try to do, like, like, at least, like, an hour and a half or so.
Oh, my gosh.
If I could pass an hour, it's already, like, a miracle.
Because I'm so dead inside.
I am...
I'm so dead inside right now.
So, we hit an hour mark.
That's, like, an accomplishment right now.
All right.
Black Talon.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, boy.
Here I go.
Hope...
Helping to finance my Oshi streams again.
Also, happy early birthday to you, Toki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And thank you again for the birthday wishes.
Thank you, guys.
Now, like I said, I'll explain more in depth about, like, the hell I was in...
For the last month.
Don't worry.
All right.
I'll explain the hells later.
We're...
Oh, yeah.
I fucking...
I fucking forgot.
I fucking had a compromise, baby.
All right.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
All right.
I forgot.
It's been so long.
I forgot about this.
Okay.
Anyway, I guess I'll talk about Marvel Rivals more.
Oh, yeah.
Did I even mention?
The new character is Phoenix, by the way.
I...
I didn't even mention what the new character was.
The new character that they've launched for this new season three, which we are previewing, is Phoenix, and she's apparently going to be DPS.
I saw a little bit about it.
I saw a little bit about, like, what she does and everything.
So, it's going to be very interesting because apparently she seems very strong.
And some of her abilities have, like, no maximum range.
So, she seems a bit busted from what I read.
So, we'll see how that goes.
Also, Yosh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I still can't believe my friend was like, no, that's actually, like, cheaper than, like, the normal industry, like, the normal pricing if you went with, if you went with, like, you know, the average pricing in JP.
And I was like, there's no way.
That was so expensive.
And she's like, no, like, like, she was like, no, you don't understand.
Sometimes there, because, okay, well, obviously, it was five figures.
So, like, like, obviously, like, it was three, four, five.
Yeah, it was five figures.
But, apparently, it can go to six figures.
And mine didn't go to six figures.
But my friend was, like, saying, like, yeah, no, like, you know, like, sometimes they go for six figures.
And I was like, what?
So, I was like, oh, my God.
Um, yes, USD, I am talking in US dollars right now.
I am.
Um, but mine wasn't.
Mine, thank God, mine was not.
But to be fair, mine was, like, um, the shaders haunt you.
Thank you for the super chat, PB.
Thank you, thank you.
I know I said I wouldn't talk about the concert, but, like, you know, I need to kill time right now, because we're compiling shaders at the moment.
Um, um, but, but mine was shorter than, uh, you know, it's not an hour long.
It was, like, around 35 minutes for the concert, which is, like, you know, like, half, basically.
So, maybe that's why I, it was, like, it didn't go to six figures.
But it was still a lot.
I was, like, it still looked really good for, like, how, like, how, like, even, it was, like, it took a month.
I didn't, like, I, like, it was a month's work.
If I had, like, more than a month, maybe I can, like, pad out more time.
But it was, like, basically, like, it was, like, seven songs, plus, seven songs, plus, MC.
So, um, so it was, like, around, like, 35 minutes, which I thought was, like, I thought, it was crazy that seven songs was just 35 minutes.
I thought I was doing so much.
I literally thought, oh, my, oh, man, this is gonna be at least 45 minutes.
And then, like, after the concert, I was, like, wait, that's only 35?
That's, like, that's, like, 30 to 35?
I was, like, oh, fuck, what?
I was, like, oh, shit, I thought we were already at, I thought I did so much.
It felt like it was going on for a while.
And, all right.
All right.
Right, oh, my God, into another loading screen.
I for, oh, shit, I forgot to, I need to log in.
All right.
Let me, I forgot to, because, like, for this version, um, you have to log in specifically to an early access account.
So, let me grab the credentials for it real quick.
All right, copy, log in.
Oh, my gosh, my brain feels so goddamn slow right now.
Log in.
Password.
All right.
Oh, my God.
I don't have my settings, too.
Because it, like, resets everything, basically, whenever you're here.
And then, like, they don't, okay.
All right.
Because I can be Doki, Braid, apparently.
Not Doki.
Can I be not Doki?
Oh, my God.
What?
Oh, I can be not Doki.
Thank you.
Okay.
Yay!
Not Doki.
Let's go.
All right, guys.
Oh, Phoenix.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
There's new emotes and everything.
All right.
We're not Doki time.
Okay.
Let's, like, make sure...
Uh...
We're gonna change our settings because it resets everything.
Whenever you're on...
Because it's basically a new account.
It's not even my account, technically.
Because it's, like, an early access account.
So, it's not even mine.
Uh...
I said 1.83, right?
1.83 cents.
Okay.
Nice.
Uh...
And then...
I assume, like...
The audio...
Okay.
And display...
Full screen...
Uh...
Low...
What's up?
The setting...
The graphics...
Um...
Transfer over.
But not the...
You would think keyboard controls would transfer over.
But it doesn't.
I don't know...
Understand why.
That's so weird.
Like, the one thing you think it should transfer over...
Doesn't transfer over.
Um...
Oh my god.
It's...
Also...
Not even my crosshair, too.
I'm just gonna do a random crosshair.
We'll do dot and then green.
That's usually what I do.
It's not my...
It's a little too thin.
It's short.
It's a little too small.
But honestly, it's okay.
Okay.
Um...
Let's see.
I need...
Communication...
I think...
Melee.
I need to do the melee.
Uh...
Melee...
And then communication...
We'll deal with this.
Sorry.
It's a little above average, guys.
But it's okay.
We can...
We can do...
It's a little above average.
Uh...
P-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p.
Alright.
Think...
We don't need to talk to people.
So we can...
Get rid of that.
They don't deserve my...
They don't deserve... my microphone.
Alright, let's look at... oh yeah, they have these new accessories now.
Where you can like basically... okay, I love how... Wait, he has a tongue?
Wait, do I have a... oh yeah, okay, so... yeah, we have accessory points now.
So, these are really interesting.
Because... Okay, I like how this looks like... okay, this one's pretty silly to me.
Because when I saw the preview for this... So, they're only like... it's only by Jeff and Psylocke.
But it's so interesting.
Because like... this looks like a nose ring.
I didn't even realize his tongue is out.
But like, he's licking her ass.
So... And you're like, what the fuck are you talking about?
Don't worry, I'll show you guys soon.
I saw like... I saw like preview pictures of it.
I was like, what the fuck?
They know what they're doing.
They actually...
And anyway, also they had a new feature.
Where if you're in university.
It apparently...
It's so like, you know, you could ruin your...
Education!
They're trying to get you while you're young.
Um, but...
If you're in university.
You can register for an account.
With your school email.
And they'll give you like, free stuff.
But it just... they get you while you're young.
And so, you know, you don't go to classes.
And you just play Marvel Rivals.
Okay.
Where the...
Alright, what is the...
Where's the new battle pass?
There it is.
Uh, that's how they get you.
Okay, and then people were talking about Squirrel Girl.
The Squirrel Girl new skin.
And like...
Not gonna lie, I understand.
I...
I understand!
So...
They're like...
The people in the comments were like...
You know what?
I'm willing to take the risk.
I'm...
She looks like a Molly from Pokemon with the tail.
Okay, yeah.
Like...
Before we were like...
You know what?
I'm...
I'm ready to take that risk.
Ooh.
Oh my god.
All those teeth.
There's gold...
There's a gold panther.
Okay, so there's a gold panther.
And...
Holy thighs!
Risking it all!
High risk.
High rewards.
Rewards.
Okay.
Weapon Phoenix.
I don't really...
Play...
Oh my god!
Wait!
They have a symbi...
Oh my god!
I didn't even realize they have a symbiotic Groot too!
This is like...
Fully like...
Symbiotic theme.
By the way, for...
Half season...
Apparently it's gonna be...
It's gonna finally be...
Blade.
For the half season new character.
That's cool.
I didn't even think they have a symbiotic Groot as well.
Oh that shit is crazy.
That's...
That's a fucking crazy skin.
Oh yeah!
Uh...
Marvel Rivals released a statement and was saying how like...
Oh yeah!
They were like...
Basically we can make any Marvel character for this game so we're not gonna run out of characters.
So...
They're saying that in the future they might do like...
A fan vote on...
And vote on like...
Um...
Which character to add next in the future.
Cause there's just so many options.
And I thought that was really nice.
And then they do...
Yeah they...
Literally can like...
Make...
That's why they're like...
Yeah we're gonna add a new hero every fucking month.
So it's basically like...
League.
It's...
It's basically...
It's basically like League.
And then that's like printing money out.
Because like...
That's...
Imagine how many skins you can do with that.
And then...
Uh...
There's Phoenix King.
Oh...
Coming soon.
Oh they don't have it yet.
Okay.
So there's Phoenix Namor.
Apparently Namor is like hella buff right now.
And they're also...
They're saying that they're like...
Yeah we wanna do like...
Characters that are not like...
As popular in the Marvel cin...
That aren't really in...
The Marvel Cinematic Universe.
So they're focusing on the more obscure characters.
Cause they're like...
Oh we want...
Oh my god.
There's...
White...
White Adam.
Alright.
Uh...
And then there's...
Black suit.
Crazy that.
There's black suit.
Oh isn't that like...
Isn't that...
That's like...
Pizza time!
Light mode.
Yeah there's...
Light mode Adam.
And night mode...
And...
Oh my god it is!
Pizza time!
It is!
It is...
To...
Tobey Maguire!
Oh...
Wait that's sick.
That's...
I think this will be the only skin I buy.
But the only emote I buy for Spider-Man.
I'm...
I'm sold.
He lives on!
Bully McGuire!
Girls only want one thing.
And it's the evil... I like how they call it the evil dance.
The only time I'll ever buy the Battle Pass.
I literally only own one emote and it's her name.
Making it rain.
But soon, I will own two emos.
Okay, that shit's... What the fuck?
There's like...
It's on the jetpack too.
Oh, I don't like his tail.
Oh, that tail is so uncom...
It looks like a tentacle.
I am so uncomfortable with...
I'm so uncomfortable with the fucking tail.
It's like...
It looks like a goddamn...
It looks like...
A goddamn tentacle.
And I...
Oh my god.
I can hear the sound effects.
Hear me out!
He's a raccoon!
You can't say hear me out!
Yeah!
He's...
He's really a raccoon!
Okay, this shit is cute.
Aww!
I like how symbiotic Jeff is just...
He's just like a...
Like a little bulldog.
Like...
We gotta pick two up.
Oh, and it's gonna be...
Devouring...
Oh, that's...
It's like an orc...
Yeah!
It's like a little orca whale!
Yeah, you're right!
Oh, that's cute!
He's a silly little guy!
Yeah!
Okay, I think...
Oh!
This one's good.
What's this?
Oh!
Alright, we gotta watch this again.
So we can actually have it...
Like a good full screen for it.
Oh!
Okay, that's cute.
What's this?
Oh, so he's like...
No!
Don't wanna leave!
Alright, and that's all...
That's all the battle pass.
That's cute!
I like some of the skins here.
I like how...
Squirrel Girl...
The Squirrel Girl skin...
Is literally like...
The first one.
They know what's...
They know...
They...
It's the...
They know what they...
They know...
Why would it be the first one?
They know what we want.
Why else?
Can I even purchase it?
Oh, I can.
Alright.
Just cause...
Just for you freaks out.
It's like...
It doesn't cross over.
So...
What's the word called?
When like...
The stuff doesn't transfer over...
Is it just it doesn't transfer over?
It doesn't transfer over to like...
Your actual account.
So I'll just claim it.
Since they...
Since they like buffed her anyway.
Yeah, there's no cross progression.
Cause it's basically a new account that they gave you.
They fucking know.
Yeah.
Hey.
Alright.
This will be the only character to help buy a skin for...
For the newest...
For the...
For the newest season.
Not so Deadpool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You did amazing today, Doki.
Congrats on your concert.
Way to get sloppy and still stay on top.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Phoenix time.
Jean... No, is it?
Jean Grey.
My only knowledge about her was in the X-Men movies.
Like, the really bad ones.
The really, really bad ones.
I was like... I feel bad.
So I was like, when did she become a good guy?
Yes.
That's my only knowledge of Phoenix.
Because, like, I think it ended on a cliffhanger on X-Men 3.
And so I was like, wait, she's good?
I'm so confused.
I was like, when did she became, like, uh... Yeah, she... Yeah.
And then, like, how did...
When did she became, like, a good guy in the end?
So I got confused during the trailer.
Um... But that was like, uh... Yeah, and then... And then she dies.
And I was like, but, like, the whole point about being Phoenix is that you can be reborn.
So, like, why does she die?
I was so confused.
I was like, my vague memories of watching X-Men 3.
And I was like, wait, she's dead?
Like, but... What... What's...
But being... How are... You're supposed to be reborn!
Oh, poor Scott, though.
Poor...
Okay, you know what's fucked up?
Um... Her boyfriend gets so little attention now...
That, like, I already forgot his, like, superhero name.
I'm just like, poor Scott.
Cyclops, yes!
I was like, I feel like...
Yeah, Cyclops always loses.
And, like, I feel like...
No one... It's been so long.
It's... It's actually been, like, so long for him.
That, like, I legitimately forgot his actual hero name.
Because...
I just feel sorry for that guy.
And I'm like, poor man.
He's... He's...
Like, in me... Like, he doesn't even...
The fact that Wolverine...
And Phoenix...
Are in Marvel Rivals.
And...
Poor... Poor Scott.
Also, fun fact.
I talked about this...
Before.
Um...
I talked about this...
Before.
But, like...
You know, like...
His laser eyes...
Aren't even lasers.
They're like...
What was it?
It's like...
Beams of Fit.
Like...
It's just a punching ray.
It's... It's like a kinetic ray.
It's not even a laser ray.
There is just...
A punch ray.
Yeah, yeah!
From the punch dimension!
There is...
His eyes is the portal to the punch dimension.
And...
It's basically a kinetic energy blast.
So they're not...
There is...
So they're not even lasers.
Uh...
They're like a gusset blast.
And he punches real...
He basically punches with his eyes.
Um...
Anyway...
Welcome...
Welcome back, Gene.
Um...
Alright, so...
Ah...
Alright, Chaos Phoenix.
What does that even mean?
His eyes are the portal to the punch dimension.
So when he opens his eyes...
He's literally punching...
He's literally sending out...
Punches with his eyes.
Ha ha ha ha...
Ha ha ha...
Ha ha ha ha!
That's...
That's banget...
That's me...
There's no such thing as lasers.
It's literally...
Punch...
Dement...
Like...
Like punch beams.
Uh...
Eh...
Okay, not... It's alright.
It's alright.
The perfect fusion of Phoenix Force and Chaos... I think this is more so... I guess like... Oh wait, no!
They invented this skin.
First appearance... I was like, oh, maybe this is a comic book skin.
But they literally made this up.
Yeah, first appearance... You know, like the first appearance?
Wait, I'll show you guys.
It's like, first appearance in Marvel Rivals Season 3.
So they literally invented this skin.
Uh... For this game.
Okay.
Uh... That's interesting.
What about this one?
They're trying to... Oh yeah, okay.
X-Men Red.
Uh... Uh... Oh, it's like a red equivalent.
I don't know.
I'm not sure.
I'm not like, too sold on this skin, to be fair.
Oh my god.
No, I think they like, Grinner baited me too hard in Marvel Rivals.
So like, they gave her just like, more clothes.
And I was like...
I mean, I'm just like... I think that's it.
I was like... No, it's actually like, pretty neat.
But I think like, Rebels actually, Grinner baited me so hard that I...
I'm like... Too much.
Super, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Paladin, thank you for the super chat.
In the comics, Cyclops is way cooler.
He even killed Professor X with powers at what...
Oh my god, he punched an old man?
That's fucked up.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Because like, the more I look at it, I do like...
I think it's just the color palette.
I'm just not a fan of the color palette.
I think that's it.
The magenta...
Um... The magenta with the fire.
I think that's it.
I think that's why I'm like, not a huge fan.
Um...
I just think... It must be the color palette.
Because I'm like, not too sold for it.
Um... I like this.
This is cool.
I like the little, like, the details on this.
Alright, let's see.
What are the MVP?
Ooh... Okay, this is gonna be so disorienting because there's two of them.
Does this have a hitbox?
It doesn't, right?
I assume, like... I assume she doesn't have a hitbox, but it's gonna be so disorienting when there's two of them flying around.
Ooh...
Oh, I'm hitting my second wind, guys.
I'm not tired anymore.
I'm... I can feel the second wind in my fucking body.
Yeah, it's like a JoJo stand.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Here comes Dokita Mutinator!
Thank you for the super chat team.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, what about... okay.
Cosmic.
Apparently, she's, like, hella... like, her DPS is, like, hella, but faster.
Launch a fire projectile forward, applying one spark to enemies hit.
Criticates apply...
Oh, it's stacked damage!
So, like, the more you hit, the more it's... like, the more damage you cause.
So, like, her DPS for hella is just a faster hella DPS.
Like, the, the left click.
Um...
Okay, so, if you have...
Okay, if you do a fiery explosion that has a stacked spark, then you can have time to heal.
Okay, Sparks will not stack within a brief period.
Alright, what's this?
Endstone Inferno.
Oh, shit.
Wait, that's it?
Dealing devastating damage hit while creating shot weight that destroys...
Oh!
It cancels everything.
Okay, so...
It destroys enemy summons, shields, and any bonus health.
Enemies hit are applied with one spark.
So, basically, if you have, like, you know, if you have, like, low-key clones, lamps...
I assume the lamps... it destroys lamps, right?
So, I'm gonna try that out later and see if it destroys lamps.
But, it can one-shot Rocky ult.
Uh...
Any type, like, turrets.
Yeah, it just strips it all away.
It also stops Hella ult, too.
Okay, so...
Yeah.
Uh...
Rocket...
Hella ult and Rocket ult are summons.
Oh, okay.
So, Rocket ult will be useless.
And everything.
So, they'll just instant...
It just instant heals everything.
Yeah, it clears all...
You activated my trap card!
And you're like...
Not so fast, Kaiba!
I put on...
I put down Phoenix, which clears all trap cards summons.
Okay.
Pot of Gre...
I play Pot of Gre...
Not so fast!
Can't catch me!
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Okay, leave behind illusion and instantly teleport in the desire.
Followed by detonating the illusion.
Enemies hit or apply...
Oh, okay.
So...
Okay, so there's a...
So I can be like...
Peek-a-boo and then TP back.
Merge with the Phoenix entering a state of free flight.
Gain a movement boost while continuously...
Okay, so that's her escape ability.
What about telekinesis first?
What the fuck is that?
The fire blast stuns enemy while the two explosion inflicts slow.
Okay, so that's like the torch's little flame thing.
Okay.
So...
I summon Dark Magician.
Dark Magician.
Okay, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Uh, Jakarta.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You want to see Cyclops and Phoenix done right?
Highly recommend seeing the new X-Men 97 and our enemies series.
Though it's a follow-up to the OG 90 show.
They make it so you can watch it on its own too.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I've heard a lot about the...
The...
Like the...
The sequel for it.
Um, and like it won a lot of awards.
And then I also heard the creator was freaking weird.
But I don't know.
I don't remember what he did.
People were like, God damn.
I wish the creator wasn't a fucking weirdo.
But I don't remember what he did.
I...
It was just...
I just saw people on Twitter talking about it.
Um...
I don't remember.
But I heard that the new show was really, really good.
Um...
That was the only reason why I heard about this show.
Because people were talking about the creator.
Being...
Fucking weird.
Um...
I didn't hear good things about that show.
Okay, so apparently Wolverine is super busted now.
Because when she...
He teams up with Phoenix.
He has...
Lifesteal.
So...
Um...
That's not cool.
That's...
Like...
I don't know what else to say.
But...
That's not very cool.
But yeah.
Basically, Wolver...
Wolverine has lifesteal now.
Alright.
What a...
Okay, wait.
We're gonna...
Alright.
How do I do this?
So apparently...
Now that...
Uh...
Okay.
Where's my menu?
Change hero.
So you...
If you change your character...
To...
Like...
With the skin and everything.
It actually changes the lobby.
Does it?
Oh, yeah.
Oh!
Wait, I like that.
It changes the lobby image too.
Yeah.
Oh!
Wait, that's cool.
I like that.
Uh...
So the lobby and everything changes too.
When you...
Um...
Uh...
Swap it.
You wanna see the Lord icon for Phoenix?
Alright.
Let's see if it's good or not.
Looks like...
Oh!
That's pretty good.
I like it.
I mean...
Compared to the default?
That's pretty nice.
I don't know about the finger.
It looks like sausage...
Sausage hands.
But other than...
Okay!
Does it not look like...
She's holding a fucking sausage?
Other than the sausage...
It's like...
Everything else looks good.
I think if they remove...
The...
The giant ass sausage finger...
Um...
It's actually pretty good.
No, it's...
It's flipping you.
No, I'm pretty sure she's like...
Like, why is this so thick?
Her finger is so thick.
It looks like...
Like, okay, it doesn't look like a baguette.
Because it's not thick enough for a baguette.
But like...
It's thick enough to be a...
Long ass sausage.
Like...
So like...
I feel like if they remove this...
It'd look pretty good.
Uh...
Alright.
New team ups.
So they added some new team up...
Team up guys.
Um...
I believe it's...
What was it?
I also gotta remove some team ups too.
Oh yeah.
This one's crazy.
Because...
Squirrel Girl can now have homing missiles too.
And this one's sad.
I'm so sad.
It's also crazy.
But it makes me sad.
So...
Um...
So Spider-Man does like...
Fire damage now too.
Like...
Yay.
Uh...
Damn it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So it burns...
Over time.
So...
Damages over time.
That shit's scary.
Uh...
The torch is already pretty broken.
And then for this one...
Um...
This is basically...
Okay.
Well...
Basically...
I saw someone on Twitter talk about it.
But...
Her...
Her missile...
Uh...
Team up.
The squirrel missiles.
Thank god she has an actual decent team up.
Uh...
Because like...
Who the fuck is playing Penny right now?
Um...
Uh...
But...
She has a homing nut.
And the thing about her homing nut...
Is that...
There's no range...
There's no maximum range from what I saw on Twitter.
Uh...
So...
That...
That sounds pretty crazy.
And then for this one...
The hella one...
Um...
It's basically...
If people are grouped up...
There's like...
Tendril to it.
So...
I assume that...
It...
Increases the...
Range.
Yeah.
Increases the range of her...
Of her...
What ability is that?
E.
Of her E.
Yeah.
She has...
You can't escape her nut.
Okay.
I believe that's all of...
Yeah.
I think that's all of...
The newer...
Stuff.
Okay.
Let's go to training.
Real quick.
I don't know...
I really remember...
Exactly.
What are...
All the new changes...
For everything?
Um...
Welcome to the training ground.
Okay.
We go.
Alright.
So let's grab...
It's nut time.
Oh.
God.
I do...
Okay.
They...
Oh.
Whoa.
Like she has a symbiotic voice too.
Nice.
Alright.
So...
Oh my god.
It's been so long since I played Squirrel Girl.
Alright.
Let's do the team up real fast.
Uh...
Wanna play her?
Alright.
So...
Yo!
We...
Yahoo!
Oh shit.
For all you tail lovers over there.
Alright.
So...
Okay.
Let me see.
Uh...
Let's do...
I need to make sure there's no cooldown.
Okay.
So...
But that's crazy.
Haha.
There's no maximum range.
Your tail is so distracting.
Haha.
High risk.
High reward.
Haha.
But the cooldown is like...
Pretty...
Pretty long though.
That's the only thing.
That makes it fair.
You have to like...
At least look at it.
So you can't be like...
360.
Oh wait.
I can.
Haha.
360.
I can be like...
Oh shit.
Okay.
Wait.
I have to...
360.
Phew.
Haha.
I can do that.
That'd be so PM.
If you die from that.
And nutting in 360.
Oh my god.
I did like a...
Six...
A nut.
Eclipse.
You have to just shoot the general direction.
Yeah.
The 360 nut.
Haha.
But that's like her...
Basically the...
The change that she has.
Alright.
What other things were different?
What other things did they change?
I could show you guys the...
Oh my god.
I forgot.
The...
The new character.
Haha.
Obviously.
Oh yeah.
No.
Oh my god.
It's so fast.
Nevermind.
This is...
Point and click adventure.
I told you guys, right?
Um...
I think Hela is the...
Easiest DPS...
Out there for...
Uh...
Is there falloff?
Wait.
Actually?
Okay.
Can't catch me.
I need to know.
What's the falloff for this?
Oh, it's not that...
Bad.
Oh no.
She is like Hela.
Oh.
Hahaha.
It...
The falloff is not that bad.
Not gonna lie.
Wow.
Four in a row.
Yeah.
It's not that...
Like there is falloff, but it's...
It's not that bad.
Hahaha.
This is a new Hela.
This is actually Hela.
Way to go!
It's been like point and click adventure.
Hahaha.
Sorry.
Oh my god.
It's been a while since I played.
I just need to like...
Practice again.
Because...
Guys.
It's been a while since I've played...
Hahaha.
I've played it.
Video games.
Hahaha.
But...
Err.
You've been judged.
Um...
If I like...
If I actually warmed up...
I think it'd be fine.
But I have not warmed up at all.
Hahaha.
It's basically Hela.
And Hela...
If you can aim...
This is like...
Pretty easy.
And it has like blasts too.
Like the fact that like...
I remember when she was a fucking telekinesis girl.
Hahaha.
You've been judged.
And then there...
People were like...
And then Marvel was like...
There's too many psychic people.
We gotta give her something else.
But her damage is...
Insane actually.
Now that I think about it.
Um...
I'm sure hope they don't add more ways to beat me senseless.
In less than two seconds.
Or...
Thank you with the super chat.
Thank you.
Hahaha.
Remember when all she did was move...
Uh...
Was just read people's minds?
That wasn't cool enough.
Let's give her fire powers.
Hahaha.
Did she get two shot?
A headshot?
Yeah.
So it's Hela.
She's literally Hela.
Now imagine if someone else also shot at that person.
I imagine two pro aimers with Phoenix.
Hela.
Okay, the other team.
Lord help us.
Hahaha.
Like...
It's literally just Hela.
But her...
Her project...
Uh...
It's not even a projectile.
I think this is...
Is this hitscan?
Is this too fast?
It feels really fast for her.
It feels really fast for projectile.
Yeah, it does more damage.
Of course.
Is it projectile?
It hitscan.
Cause it feels...
It feels like hitscan.
Like...
The fact that it's faster than Hela is like insane.
Cause like...
Her...
She's already...
Hela was already super fucking easy.
Hahaha.
And then you have like...
Okay, so how...
Cause like...
Gene has...
Really?
You know, I would love to have a teleporting ability as a support.
That would be pretty cool if you think that.
Hahaha.
But no.
Give it to Gene.
Haha.
But like...
You know how Hela has the bird?
So Gene Gray has...
Um...
Yeah, she has this.
She has two fucking...
What the fuck?
She's so greedy!
She...
She's like...
No, I want more.
No, I want it all.
She's so fucking greedy.
Oh my god.
She has the fly.
And then she has her...
Stupid...
She has this.
So she actually has the teleport that...
And her ship...
Her ship makes it so that...
The ship...
It makes it that it explodes.
So I can literally do like...
Can't catch me!
I can like do this...
And then...
Teleport away.
Oh my...
Her greed sickens me!
Her...
Hahaha.
I can feel your pain.
Sorry.
What the...
What can Adam do?
Adam can just walk...
Can just walk away.
Like...
Oh my god!
Her greed...
Why does she have two escape abilities?
That's...
Hahaha.
That's so fucked up.
Let's just notice that.
She has two fucking escape abilities.
Holy shit.
And just...
Just walk away.
Alright.
Bro, they like broke his legs.
Cause they're like, You're not allowed to have friends anymore.
And then...
Uh...
I've seen enough...
Nerf Adam's mobility.
Hahaha.
No, they're like...
They're like...
They're like, You know what?
You can't even have friends, Adam.
We're nerfing Rose Cop.
No more friends for you.
And then they went and buffed Mantis?
Hahaha.
So yeah.
By the way.
Mantis got a little buff, so...
She does more healing now.
Um...
They're like...
You don't deserve friends.
Hahaha.
I'm mad.
They hate him so much.
Hahaha.
Um...
I just know that...
Her healing...
Like...
Her healing increased too.
Uh...
And Sue has more healing as well.
Yeah.
Um...
What the fuck does Adam have?
I mean...
He doesn't have anything.
Um...
Oh yeah.
I wanted to try out...
I wanna try out the Wolverine life steal real quick.
Okay.
So...
I don't play Wolverine.
I don't remember...
Oh, I need to get damage first.
I don't play Wolverine.
But I just wanna see the life steal.
In general.
He's the...
Yeah.
He's the middle child.
Alright.
Hahaha.
Okay.
So...
How do I activate it?
How do you activate the...
Oh!
There we go.
Okay.
Wow!
Whoa!
Nevermind.
I see.
I see now.
No, I see it now.
Oh, whoa.
It's the shift.
Yeah.
Uh...
Oh, bring the game down a little bit?
Sure.
I can do that.
Uh...
It...
Okay.
The thing is...
Imagine like...
You broke the guy's...
Uh...
Passive.
And then he has life steal after that.
Can you try on a tank?
Oh, yeah.
Let me grab a tank real quick.
Can I like...
Do it from here?
Like...
Give me a tank.
No, I can't spawn a tank from here.
Alright.
Let me grab this here.
Alright, thing.
Wait, I can't grab him.
Okay.
Alright, Groot.
It's time.
Alright.
It's time, Groot.
It's time.
Yeah!
And then...
I don't know.
Yay!
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
And I'm full HP now.
Goodbye.
Now imagine if I grab two people.
Cause like...
That's life stealing from one guy.
And usually Wolverine...
Wolverines can grab like several people too.
Oh my god.
If he like...
Ults too?
Oh, that shit would be crazy.
That shit would actually be crazy.
And I'm not even a Wolverine player.
I think Wolverine might get banned.
It's like...
He seems really strong with...
The...
The Phoenix team up.
Alright.
Uh...
What else do I wanna try out?
Oh yeah.
I wanna try our ult.
Go back to...
The...
Gene real quick.
It's...
Okay.
So her ult...
Weeeeee!
Yeah.
There you are.
Alright.
So...
Apparently her ult has no range.
You are nothing!
Weeeeee!
Okay.
How far can I go though?
Oh my god.
I can dive bomb so fucking far.
Okay.
Give me...
Give me her...
Alright.
Let's see.
How far can I go?
I'm curious.
You are nothing!
Okay.
As long as I can see where they are.
Weeeee!
Okay.
I need to make sure I don't land on structures.
Alright.
That's good.
I was wondering if I can...
If I like get...
If I TP through the structures.
That's why I did that.
Because I was curious how broken that is.
So like...
As long as like...
I'm in the air.
And then...
Weeeee!
Okay.
Yeah.
There's no actual range.
I have to actually...
Oh!
And I...
It TP's me back?
Wait.
What?
Oh!
So I...
Dive bomb?
I can like...
Oh!
So I'd be safe.
I'd just...
Be back.
Oh!
So like...
It doesn't...
Yeah.
So it's a safe ult.
So like...
I don't risk anything.
At all.
You've been judged.
Yeah.
And...
Oh!
That's interesting.
That's actually interesting.
Like...
I can literally be like...
Here.
And then like...
Huh.
Goodbye.
And then I can be back home.
Oh!
It's...
The third...
The third escape ability!
I've seen too much.
You know what?
I think Adam should do less damage.
Like...
I've seen too much, guys.
Oh!
I forgot about her right click.
Um...
You know...
I'm like super...
You can just...
Fly around with her like...
Time to nerf Adam again.
Oh!
Shit!
Okay.
Oh!
She seems so broken.
The more I'm playing around with her...
Oh!
I can shoot the...
Okay.
That's good to know.
That's good to know that you can shoot it.
Cause I was gonna say...
Like...
Do you really need more?
Yeah.
She has the right click.
So the right click basically...
Okay.
I'm going to...
Uh...
Also I brought the game volume down a little bit.
So let me know that's better sound guy.
So basically...
It like...
It does like damage...
Holy shit.
Wait.
What?
It moves?
It moves...
Oh my...
Okay.
I didn't realize that.
I thought it would just stay there.
Okay.
It's like a ballistic missile coming.
Oh!
It moves forward.
Oh my god.
Okay.
So...
I can like...
Farm so much shit.
On like...
Tanks that are just walking.
Oh that's cool.
Oh my god.
Bro.
What the fuck?
Hahaha.
Holy...
Okay.
I think they're nerfing her.
I think they're gonna nerf her on launch.
There's no way.
She has too much.
This one of these team up as a tank play.
I guess suffering is always a...
I told you guys.
All tank players are just masochists.
Look at this.
But speaking of tank.
At least you guys can like...
Jump up.
Now.
What is it?
You guys can be like...
Look.
Watch this.
I can be like...
You know what?
Fuck you.
Wait.
What was it?
Was it like...
I don't remember which jump it was.
It was like...
A particular jump.
What jump was it that makes it so you can like...
Jump up into a flyer?
And like...
Smack them.
Like...
Hahaha.
Is it Eb?
Okay.
You guys can now...
Like...
If they have a flyer...
You can just like...
Jump up to them now.
So...
Poop poop.
Pew pew.
It's like you swat them down.
Poop poop.
Boop poop.
But like...
That's really it.
Hahaha.
You're so greedy.
Why do you want more?
Anyway.
She seems too weak now.
We should like...
Give her a forfeitscape ability.
Uh...
Hahaha.
He should...
Uh...
Have to time...
Oh, you have to time the right click.
Hahaha.
Alright.
She's not broken.
She's just lore accurate.
Guys.
Alright.
I can't wait to play.
I can't wait to fight for Jean.
Okay, wait.
We gotta figure out.
Alright.
When we load in...
Where is she?
Oh my gosh.
She's all the way there.
Okay.
I could be like...
I have to like...
Be so fast.
Because I think everyone's gonna be playing her.
I...
Hahaha.
Okay.
Alright.
Is there anything else to check out, guys?
Before I...
Play quick play.
And check out the new map.
Wait.
Actually, we should check out the new map.
Uh...
On custom.
I already looked...
I think...
Uh...
Go healer next scroll.
We need...
You know what?
I've seen enough.
We gotta remove Adam's legs.
I...
Hahaha.
I still can't believe they were like...
At the nerf rest cop.
If you're like, Adam, you don't deserve friends.
Hahaha.
They like buffed Mantis instead of buffing Adam.
That's so fucked up.
Hahaha.
Alright.
Um...
Remove his ability.
You're right, guys.
You know what?
He should...
He should just start crawling.
Uh...
Alright.
Let's look at the new map, Tim.
Hahaha.
Because legless.
Okay.
Um...
Hmm...
Alright.
So there is a new map.
Let's be friends.
Hahaha.
That was so simple.
Thank you for the rain.
Thank you.
Alright.
Create game.
No one's allowed in my game.
Lock room.
Alright.
Uh...
I don't know.
I mean, no one's gonna be in here anyway.
Hahaha.
I just...
I don't even know my own password.
Alright.
Let's see.
What...
What mode is it anyway?
It is a...
Not that.
What's it called?
Wait, what the fuck is it called?
Wait, what is the new map called?
Oh, it's Haven.
Is it not in?
No.
Oh, it's Klyntar.
Right?
It's Klyntar.
Oh, it's a domination map.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's look at Klyntar real quick.
It's the last one.
Alright.
Before we go into quick play.
I wanna see the map.
Pick your hero or villain.
I'm not judging.
Okay.
It doesn't...
Which is the fastest?
I guess like...
Star-Lord.
Star-Lord to fly around.
Yeah.
Klyntar is the newest map.
Also...
Borat.
Thank you for the one gifted ship.
Thank you.
Super.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, just a bit more.
Was it too loud earlier, guys?
Um...
Earlier, we were playing around sound settings.
We were playing around sa...
Like, my mic settings.
Uh...
With the sound team.
So, uh...
My sound settings might be like...
Fucked up for a bit.
Hahaha!
Alright.
Okay.
It looks like...
This map looks like...
Um...
What was that other map?
The other map that I fucking hate.
Because it was just...
Basically looks like this.
Uh...
It looks like...
This map makes my skin crawl every time.
Oh, wait.
Iron Man.
You're right.
I should just play Iron Man.
At least I can float around.
It looks like the...
Um...
The other map that I fucking hate.
Hahaha!
It looks...
Wait.
It's literally just that map.
This is that map.
What the fuck?
One.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
Wait.
There is this map.
There is!
Yeah.
They just like got rid of the cart.
It's the same planet.
Ugh.
I hate this area.
Okay.
I don't like...
I don't like this map.
I'm gonna say it.
Because like...
It just reminds me of the other map that I hate.
I'm going in with pre...
Pre-hate.
I...
Hahaha!
I'm going in...
I'm going in with pre-hate.
The fuck is this DNA shit?
Up here.
Why is your DNA here?
Alright.
Hahaha!
I'm going in with prejudice against this place.
I don't know.
It just feels like...
Uh...
Predeterminate.
I already hate the first Venom map anyway.
Uh...
Oh my god.
I'm here to get DNA.
Is there like anything different?
You're in control.
That shows up?
I don't know.
Uh...
Doesn't seem like...
That special.
Environmentally.
I think it's just cause like...
Corko...
Corkoa was like...
Super...
Detailed.
And like...
It was such a new area.
And as well.
That like...
Seeing this is a little underwhelming.
Just because it's like...
You know...
They just...
It's like...
The same planet.
And it feels like...
It feels like very...
Uh...
What's it called?
It feels very samesy.
Okay.
These are the things you can break.
Oh.
I can break this.
Uh...
It feels just a little underwhelming.
Just because like...
We just got...
Like...
Krakoa was a...
We got Krakoa and the...
The other map wasn't...
I didn't like the...
What was it?
The one with the...
Roots and stuff?
Alright.
I wonder what the second cycle is.
Keep going!
Yeah.
This feels a little boring.
Alright.
Come on.
Speed it up, guys.
I think it's just the colors.
I think the colors...
And the fact that I...
I fucking hate the other one.
I...
I don't know.
I just...
I never liked that...
Other map.
For it.
The first map for this...
Planet.
Because it's like the...
Little black goo's.
These things.
Little black goo shit.
And also like...
Um...
I don't know.
I just never liked that map in general.
When I...
To play it.
They're like...
I'm already coming in with predetermined hate.
I'm...
I'm already...
I'm already coming with prejudice right now.
I wonder if there's any like goo that you can...
You can break that.
You can break all of this.
Alright.
I don't know what the new area is.
Yay!
I got DNA!
Okay, Celestial Vulp.
Alright.
What does the Celestial Vulp grant me?
If I'm not joking about something, you know I'm not taking it seriously.
Okay.
Oh, it just looks the same.
This just looks like the starting area for...
The...
The first map.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
This looks the same.
What change?
Yeah.
I'm like...
What change?
I guess...
I guess cause like, you know...
Um...
It's like, you know...
This battle pass is like Venom themed.
So it makes sense to like, make it more so like...
You know, lots of Venom related things here.
But they are the same picture.
I can't tell what's different, guys.
I actually can't tell.
Weeeeee!
Okay, so...
It looks like the same from...
I don't know.
It feels very similar to...
It feels very similar to the first stage.
Okay, there's Hello.
Hello, hello!
It looks like the mission area...
Yeah, just a little blend.
I agree.
What's destructible?
Not a lot!
Wait.
Wait a minute.
What?
Really?
Oh!
Oh, that's interesting.
Not a lot is destructible here.
This?
What the fuck is that gonna do to me?
Oh, that's interesting.
Usually, usually, like, more things are destructible, so the fact that, like...
I guess, like, the entrance?
But, like, what the fuck are you gonna do here?
That's, like, literally their spawn.
Yeah, I'm just, like, thinking.
This is, like, their spawn.
Natani!
Oh, no, Doki, be careful!
You're gonna stub your toe!
Like that!
Don't worry, I got you.
I got that spike out of the way.
Don't worry, Doki.
Oh, is it the sword talking to me?
Oh, shit!
It is!
Oh, it's the sword talking to me.
Yeah, there's not a lot of destructibles here, which I'm very surprised.
Because usually, there's, like...
There should be more.
Like, I think I just broke one spike and that was it.
Uh...
Alright.
Maximum pulse!
Woo!
Okay, so I got rid of that tree.
But it's, like, I don't know.
There's no...
It doesn't seem like there's a point in destroying any of these.
Just because, like...
All of this seems like...
You have to be in their spawn to get this.
The talking sword.
Yeah, but they have a talking sword, Doki!
10 out of 10!
Alright.
I like how...
Oh, yeah, because it's a...
Like, a cat and mouse.
You just run around.
It was, like, a 1v1 and then you just run around the sword in the middle.
Oh, you're right.
I guess, like, Rocket could climb and...
And...
Could climb on that.
Alright, let's see if we get the Celestia...
Uh, hand.
Also, Headhunter!
Thank you for the raid!
Thank you!
I appreciate it!
Thank you so much!
Alright.
I wanna see the...
Maybe the...
Um...
The third zone would be different.
Alright.
I hope I get the third zone.
Celestia Husk.
Pick your hero!
Wait, no.
I don't know...
I don't know what that was.
What was it called?
What was the third zone called, guys?
I don't remember what it was called.
Maybe the third one will be different.
Is this the first zone?
Okay, we'll just immediately end match.
Okay.
This round is invalid.
Okay, it's called Celestia Hand.
Still capture the Celestia Husk?
Or maybe when you get in, it's different, right?
Maybe.
I have no idea.
I'm gonna see if I get in, and if it's a different zone.
Cause I don't know.
I wish I could pick the...
Yeah, I wish...
They add...
They do add a lot of, like...
Quality of Life stuff changes every half season.
So maybe...
Later on, you can pick it during custom...
I guess, like...
Oh, there it is!
It's different?
Oh, yeah!
This is the inside.
Yeah, there it is.
Okay.
Okay, this looks different.
Okay, I like this.
You can see the little Phoenix stuff, too.
I like this area.
Yeah.
Okay.
I like that.
This is different.
It's different colors.
Oh!
Okay, see?
Look, this is nice.
Look, see?
They have, like, weapons and stuff.
They have, like, magma swords.
Yeah, this is actually, like...
Something fresh and new.
It's actually, like...
They add...
Okay, I know what's expected to say.
But the red actually adds a different color palette.
There's actually a different color palette because they added red.
Okay, that's destructible.
Oh, okay.
That's destructible.
Alright, that's interesting.
Okay, yeah.
Okay, I like this.
The third...
Wait!
The third one's nice!
Wait, the third one's actually really good!
Okay, this map is cool.
Alright.
This is actually different from the first two.
Yeah, and then they have this area for flankers.
Too.
What can I destroy?
Okay, so you can destroy this.
Yeah, you can destroy more things here.
You can add...
Oh, and then you can destroy this.
Yeah, like...
I actually have stuff I can destroy.
Alright.
Like, obviously...
And then there's, like, pathways.
The third one stole all the budget.
Yeah, and there's pathways on top.
There's, like, the balcony here.
It reminds me of that one...
What Overwatch map is it?
It reminds me of that one Overwatch map.
Where you're also, like, in a factory setting.
Where there's, like, a little balcony on top, too.
Uh, does anything collapse?
I don't think so.
What is this?
It's mostly just walls.
Yeah, uh...
Yeah, it's just walls.
I don't think anything collapsed here.
You can just make bigger...
You can just make holes in the wall.
I mean, get rid of this.
That's not...
I mean, that's sort of collapsible.
He doesn't have, like, high ground anymore.
No, no.
It's the one where you're inside.
And they have a little, like, balcony here.
Similar to this map.
Where, like, snipers can just aim...
Like, not snipers, but you can just aim down.
So you have to challenge high ground.
I guess, like, when you win this point...
You have to challenge high ground here.
Because, like, that seems, like, scary in general.
Um...
But yeah, no.
I think this is...
I think this is an interesting point.
I like this point.
And then they have this...
Oh, look!
There's, like...
Nothing growing inside there.
Never mind.
Oh, it's above me!
Oh my god!
There's a giant fucking egg!
Okay.
There's a...
There's a giant egg in front of me.
Oh, that's cute.
Yeah, I like this.
This is...
This is an interesting map.
Uh...
I look...
I look down.
Instead of...
I'm looking up.
I was like...
Oh, there's nothing in here.
Oh, there it is.
Never mind.
There's a giant fucking egg up here.
Okay.
I like this area.
Alright.
Now, let's try it.
Let's see if we can get Gene.
It's a draw?
Gamers don't look up.
Alright.
Let's see if we can actually play Gene, chat.
Oh, is that what it looks like when you lose?
Oh, when you draw?
Oh, that's cool.
Yay!
I'm MVP.
I did nothing at all.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's try a new map.
MVP!
Let's go!
Uh...
Alright.
Celestial.
I blew up some stuff, guys!
MVP!
Oh, bring game down a little bit more?
I don't know if I did that already.
But I'll do that again.
Just in case.
Sound guy, let me know.
Let me know if everything's...
Also, sound guy!
We might have to redo our sound...
Our game sound settings.
For like, Elden Ring and Halo 2.
Because of it.
I have a faster internet than everybody.
I have a...
I have an SSD compared to everyone.
Not only do I have a faster internet, but I also have an SS...
SSD.
Yeah, that's right.
I literally...
I'm pretty sure I loaded it instantly compared to everybody else.
Alright.
Like, it took them so long to pick one character.
That's crazy.
It actually took everybody so long.
Alright.
SSD different.
Diff plus...
Plus internet.
Maybe it's just...
No, cause like, audio settings all transfer over.
Like, this is like, the usual audio settings I play with.
That's some serious tech you're wearing there.
It's more than just a pseudobot.
They don't pick... No.
Well, I mean like, first trap...
Okay, so...
My team isn't bots.
I won't...
I think it would most likely be like, the enemy team that are bots.
But like, I don't think it's bots.
I think it's just like...
It's just actual like...
It's actual players.
I'm pretty sure.
One.
All you need to do is...
Capture the mission agent.
Wait.
Okay, I need to like...
Figure out what are the...
Movement stuff.
I don't know.
Some of my...
Every time I did early access...
It hasn't been like...
Ha!
Jesus Christ.
It is like...
Oh,
okay.
Wait.
Go ahead.
Alright.
Okay.
Maybe they're bots.
Nevermind.
But the way they're playing...
They better be bots.
This is sad.
I don't know.
I can't tell.
Maybe you're right.
I don't know.
Hello.
Yeah.
It seems like...
Okay.
Now I hope they're bots.
Cause this is sad.
I think...
My team is real though.
I'm pretty...
My team's real.
Like this team is...
Now I hope they are.
Just...
Cause that's embarrassing.
Okay.
I need to like...
Figure out the range for this though.
I'm like...
Oh no.
Wait.
I can't land on this.
I was like...
Wait.
There's so many...
Oh there's way too many cover.
I was like...
Oh shit.
Okay.
There's not that all...
I didn't know.
I don't know this map.
I didn't know how many trees there are.
There's so many trees!
If this guy is real, I feel bad for him.
Also him too.
Okay.
Alright.
Hello everybody.
Oh no.
I know.
Oh my god.
Poor Betty!
He doesn't deserve that!
There we go.
The count of UFO mill and mobile scenery.
Who put...
Yeah.
Who put that tree there?
Spawn camping.
Well I...
I picked...
The...
I picked her first.
So...
I think the enemy team is bots.
But my team isn't.
I don't think my...
Oh my melee is on the phoenix...
The...
The entity.
That's not all player behavior.
No, look at him.
No, they're...
Look at him.
He's punching...
He's punching women.
So I think he's real.
Alright.
I think he's real.
True.
I'm pretty sure the Hulk is real.
That Hulk is definitely a person.
Four.
Three.
Two.
One.
Okay.
Cause every time I've done like the early access the first game...
This first game my team was real.
But then like the enemy team is like 50-50.
Sometimes they're real and sometimes they're not.
So I can't tell.
Okay.
Our enemies are here.
My name...
Oh.
Okay.
I'll just stay here then.
I was just like where?
Oh.
You know I fucked this guy in particular.
Where am I?
Where did I go?
Oh.
Alright.
Nice.
We did it.
Let's go up.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
I know you'll be dead.
So I don't have to look at him.
What the fuck was that?
Uh...
Well it's more so like...
It's just cancelled summons.
So...
Um...
Get over here.
Hahaha.
Get over you little stupid fly.
That's right.
Oh my god.
If I was like an actual DPS player.
Imagine...
Like...
Like I could kill everyone.
Basically.
Oh shit.
Goodbye.
Like I can actually...
If I was an actual DPS player.
I'd be killing so many people.
Cause it's like...
A point and click adventure.
It's literally a point and click adventure.
Hahaha.
Hello.
Like I just gotta hit my shot.
Oh my god.
This is so dumb.
This character.
Okay.
I hate the healing.
Where are they?
Oh.
Bob win.
All right.
Goodbye.
Hulk.
Oh.
Don't worry.
I'm coming over.
Weeeee.
Hello little.
Hello bot.
Hello little guy.
Alright.
A true SSD test here.
After this game.
I've seen enough.
We gotta break... We gotta... Yo, fuck this one guy in particular.
We gotta nerf Adam.
I've seen enough.
Someone stretch my back.
Poor... There was no opportunity to use my hand.
Just throwing it there.
Alright.
Now, next game it should be a real test.
Big victory!
Big win!
That brain ball!
I've seen enough.
Take away Adam's res.
Alright.
Oh yeah.
They added... They changed the...
The... So you know when you're unlocking the Lord icon and stuff too.
Alright.
Now, the next game should be like a true...
Like... A true real player versus real player.
I think.
I hope.
Alright.
I wonder if there's like Doom practice.
There's actual people in Doom.
There should be, right?
Alright.
Okay.
Never mind.
It's just me.
That skin is... I don't know.
I... I like this skin more than...
Her... Um... Her legendary cosmetic in general.
It's just me.
I'm the only one here.
Hello, everybody.
I'm so lonely.
Anyone wanna come into Doom?
Oh, it sucks.
I wanna use the bathroom.
But like, I wanna make sure I get... Jean.
I... I wanna make sure I get it!
It's the ultimate test...
Of...
It's the ultimate test of like...
Who has a better PC and internet.
For the next game.
Lonely...
I'm lonely...
Mr. Lonely...
I have nobody...
To call my own...
Oh, yeah.
I should check the...
Top 500 icon too.
For next season.
To be fair, I haven't like been grinding at all.
To be fair.
I hit Eternity and then I just stopped playing.
Um...
Like...
It's just... I don't know.
I just don't have time.
I don't have time to grind at all.
Like the...
Marble Rivals...
You know like how I was supposed to stream at least like...
I think like...
Uh...
At least 25 hours of Rivals every...
Month?
Um...
But I haven't been doing that.
For...
Cause I just don't have time.
Haha, I just...
I just didn't have time.
They're like...
Oh yeah, can you.
Like you can send us your like stream stat?
Like stream hours?
Rivals?
And I was like...
I'm sorry.
I...
I don't have any.
They're like...
Oh my god...
Oh we know...
We noticed that you like didn't stream any.
Can you like...
Explain why?
I'm just like...
I'm just so busy.
I'm sorry.
What can we do to interest you more?
To stream more rivals.
And okay, she's like... I did not expect it.
I was literally just fucking around.
I'm just like, it's not you.
It's me.
I'm sorry.
It's not you.
It's me.
I hear her.
Oh my god, I hear her footsteps.
I think she hears me and she doesn't know either.
She's like, where the fuck is she?
And I'm like, where the fuck are you?
Hello.
I hear- Oh, is she above me?
I think she is.
Yeah, I think she's above me.
Like on the roof and shit.
I'm pretty sure.
I don't remember what does what do.
Wait, where is she now?
Oh, she's gonna show up now.
Oh, that was good.
Okay, she's definitely been playing.
He's definitely been playing Phoenix.
I'm just like, cause I don't have a grasp on the abilities yet.
On like what to do on the abilities.
Cause I'm still confused.
Still dead.
I think it's just aim.
Yeah, cause like that.
I don't have- I don't have the grasp on the abilities stuff.
Especially with like, right click.
Alright.
I think she's just- I think she- I think she overtakes Hela.
Honestly, she gives more- I think her- She has more like- She has like heals too, over time.
If you land your fire strike stuff.
She has her like, little heals.
Honestly, I think she is a better Hela.
Not the-
Yeah, see I get like- There's like the heals too.
Why not both?
I think you need- I don't know if you need two.
I think you have to have like a- Depending on the comp you're playing against people.
Um.
I feel like she's just- She could be just a better Hela.
I don't know.
Yeah.
He's definitely- Uh.
Hela- Yeah, Hela but with three escape abilities.
This- Where is my game?
It's a new map!
Where's my game?
Is everybody just in a custom lobby?
I think everybody- Please, I just wanna play at least one game on this new map with real things.
They got a game before I was here first!
How did they get a game?
Oh no shit, they're back.
Okay.
They're back.
I was gonna be like- How did he get the- I- I'm so confused.
Okay, he's back.
He just was like- He's like, I'm gonna reset.
I don't wanna fight this Doki person.
I guess they don't know what they're doing.
I'm like, true.
True.
I do not know what I'm doing.
No, I am.
I'm in queue.
See on the top?
It says, in queue.
I've been in- Okay, if like- We don't get a game in the newest- Uh-
Oh my god.
The- the- Oh my god.
I'm gonna say Phoenix 1v1 is like- Not fun.
Cause there's so much.
To keep track of.
Phoenix 1v1 is not fun.
Too much thinking.
There's way too much thinking involved.
Yeah, like- This guy definitely knows the movement for Phoenix already.
I'm just like- Bro, I'm tired.
I can't think right now.
Like, what the fuck?
No, I think it's- I'm also really tired from- I didn't get a lot of sleep today.
Uh, because of the concert prep.
So I didn't get a lot of sleep.
Yeah, she has like- Too many- Like- The 1v1 of- It's fun to like- Beat people up.
But like- Like- Oh, she's not good against corridors.
I think.
Maybe?
Corridor's not good for- If you're doing a Phoenix 1v1.
Oh my god.
Okay, if we don't get a game in- Aw, he's just gonna grab- There we go.
Okay, I thought he was gonna grab the health pack.
But he didn't.
I think it's whoever gets the right click off first.
Because she got the right click off of me twice.
I think that's it.
It's whoever gets the right click off of the other Phoenix wins the 1v1.
Yeah, see?
I got the right click off.
That's basically it.
I like- I sort of figured it out.
For 1v1s.
Cause like the right click does so much damage on squishies.
Cause like- Especially they're walking into it.
And like- She's won a lot of them because she-
Oh my- No!
Fuck!
I whiffed that.
Alright, fuck this.
I'm queuing regular match.
Fuck this.
I'm gonna- Queue up- Uh- The regular quick play.
Maybe I'll get one from regular quick play.
I think I'm gonna get one from regular map.
The whiff- Yeah, I whiffed that.
No, that's just doom match.
It's not- It's not uh-
It's not like- That's just doom- Doom match.
So like- So like- If you hit the right click, you get heals over time.
Okay, wait.
I think?
Was it?
No, it's the stack.
Okay, it's the stack.
As soon as you stack it, you get the heal.
Oh, okay.
So I just need to hit continuously.
That's it.
Yeah, we gotta nerf Adam.
Okay, so if I get the stack, I hit it.
This is also like- But the right click already gives you one stack.
So...
Yeah, I get that.
So as long as I hit like, one right click, I get the- Uh, I get the stack in general.
I understand!
Where are my players?
Please!
I just wanna- Let me do one game.
At least give me one game on Gene.
That's all I want.
I want one game.
Haha.
Jesus, that's crazy.
I just want one game!
Also, sound guy, has the- Is the sound okay for the rivals?
I'm- So I can like make that as the- As my usual default setting for rivals.
Everyone went to sleep- Please!
I just- Let me play one match!
I just wanna know!
I don't know how they just started.
There's no way.
I started the early access too late?
Or some shit?
No way.
I think... Oh, I think people are just doing custom lobbies, maybe.
Yeah.
But, like, custom lobbies are so awkward because, like, people want you all to join the VC.
Okay, I don't like doing the custom lobbies because they all want you to join the VC.
And then, like, but, like, and so, like, you can coordinate who gets to play Gene.
So, like, I don't want to deal with that.
I don't want to... I don't want to join VC.
And they, like, expect you to calm and stuff because they're like, oh, we're...
Because it's like, oh, we're all content creators, so let's all try and make content together and...
And, like, talk to each other.
And I'm like, no, I'm anti-social.
I'm tired.
I didn't... I don't want to talk to people right now.
You might be... I'm pretty sure they're nice people.
I just don't want to talk to anyone right now.
I... I don't... I... This is my content.
I... I'm not gonna make a YouTube video out of this.
I just want to try out her character kit.
And then go back to support at rank.
Like...
This is... This is the only time I get to play DPS.
And it's when they release DPS characters.
Wait.
That's all it took?
Really?
I just wanna... I just... And then I have to go back to support... Oh my god.
I have to go back to support duty anyway when I play on my main.
Yeah.
Did you just get done with a fucking 3D concert?
That's right.
With three hours of sleep?
That's okay, right.
Alright.
I need, like, use the shift more... better.
I use the shift to go to places, but I feel like the shift is better to use...
As safe as an escape ability.
I don't know.
Okay.
I'm sad.
Where the fuck is my...
Quick play match?
Alright.
We're gonna wait until... If I don't get a game within...
Uh...
If I don't get a game within, like...
I don't know.
Eight minutes?
When it hits eight minutes, I still don't get a game?
I'll check the custom lobbies.
I'll...
I'll roam into the custom lobbies.
I think this is the first season where, like, the games are harder to find in general.
Because I feel like I didn't start off that...
The thing is, I feel like I didn't start off...
I didn't start off that late, too, for early access.
I literally did my stream...
Because, like, early access was out for the regular players.
The ones that don't get paid.
I can feel your pain.
Um...
At four.
And I started my stream at, like...
I don't know, what was it?
5.15?
And then, like, I started queuing up at, like, six.
So...
What, was it six or 6.30?
It was, like, you know, two and a half...
It was, like, two and a half hours.
I guess, like, a lot of...
Um...
I don't know.
Maybe everybody was done after two and a half hours.
Yeah, but it's more so, like, the content creator side, though.
That sucks.
I think a lot of them just decided to do custom lobbies.
Maybe.
And in, like, two and a half hours, you're like, alright, we recorded everything we need for content.
Yeah, all the content was made during my yapping.
Goddammit.
And compiling shaders.
At least I'm, like...
I'm doing, like, uh, aim trainer right now.
I'm just aim training at the moment.
Yeah.
There is a serv...
No, that's where the custom lobbies are.
But I really don't want...
I don't...
I personally just don't want to join custom lobbies.
Because you're expected to, like, communicate with people.
Join the custom lobbies.
And actually, like, work together.
I'm too tired for that right now.
I have another stream later today.
I cannot be bothered.
I...
I really...
I cannot be fucking bothered.
I just want to play...
I swear, if I do get a game within the eight minute mark.
Um, and then I don't get to play Gene.
It's just never meant to me.
It...
I'm just covaxing right now.
It's literally never meant to be.
Her right click is so crazy, though.
I feel like...
If there's...
They're at the choke, and you can just...
Because I think you can use your right click twice.
Like...
They're just walking forward.
Like, that shit is crazy.
The spam.
Because it's like, what?
An eight second cooldown?
I think he can, like...
He can spam that, like, twice.
I'm pretty sure.
Like, if they're in the choke.
Like, this shit is insane.
Alright.
I'm covaxing.
Because I have not played...
I have not...
Played in...
Okay, and then be like, Oh, but what about Halo?
Okay.
Halo is so different.
Like, I haven't played an actual...
Aim game in, like, a while.
I think, like, in, like...
A week and a half now?
I'm pretty sure.
So, like...
I could feel my aim being, like, a little...
Like...
Rusty.
So, this is, like, the most aim I've got in a while.
Guys, I'm not aiming in Elden Ring.
I have no depth perception for that.
Yeah, I'm super rusty right now.
I can tell.
So, I'm, like...
I'm, like, trying to...
Unrusty-rust myself at the moment.
Oh, my god.
It's eight minutes.
Alright.
It's time to venture into the lands of custom lobbies.
It's time.
It's time to brave the worlds.
And then, like, we're not even gonna find a game.
Kill it.
Alright.
It's time to brave the lands.
Okay.
But what about nine minutes?
Alright.
What about nine...
Okay.
I'll do one...
I'll do ten minutes.
If we can't find a game within ten minutes, we'll brave...
Oh, I'm by myself again.
I'm...
I'm gonna switch the lights.
Gotta be a person.
I have to be a...
Goddamn...
person!
No!
Oh, the up?
Okay.
Cherry.
I'll show you guys the up.
I'll passively...
Oh, hey.
There's caboose.
There's...
Goodbye.
Nevermind.
There's no caboose.
Okay.
One more minute.
Come on.
Give me a game in one minute.
It's all I want.
Come on, buddy.
You know you want to.
Just one game.
Where I don't have to actually interact with people.
And I can just go...
Pew, pew, pew.
I just wanna shoot a person in game.
In game, guys.
No!
Alright, guys.
It seems I might...
Okay.
We can't get into a custom lobby.
It's just...
We just got it.
Like...
We did all we could.
We saw...
What G was like against bots.
I think that's good enough.
That's like...
Basically...
The regular ELO anyway.
That's just the average ELO.
It's almost the same thing.
It's all...
I am in quick play.
I've been in two...
I've queued quick play for the new map.
And also the...
Also the quick play for the non new maps.
Alright.
It's time.
My...
Cancel.
Match.
Alright.
Custom game.
Wait, isn't this...
Oh.
Okay.
He left.
I was gonna say.
Who's this?
I don't know who all of these people are.
Okay.
Here.
Oh my god.
They are all here.
Is that...
Okay.
We are a six stack.
Are you...
Okay.
Who's doing...
They are all actually in the custom...
Oh my god.
Everybody was just stacking custom lobbies.
I...
I'm fucking kidding me.
Everyone is actually just...
Oh my god.
Hey.
Everyone was actually...
Literally just playing custom lobbies.
Holy fuck.
Like...
Everybody has friends.
Not fair.
Wait.
This is EU.
These are all...
This is an EU six stack.
Oh my god.
They're not gonna start.
Is there like...
Okay.
Uh...
Which one did I join?
I don't even remember.
Okay.
Is it this?
Are they...
Who's the leader here?
Guys.
Please.
I just...
Wanna play.
I...
Stay.
Okay.
Do not leave.
Oh.
But we're gonna like fight.
Okay.
Also like...
We're all just gonna fight for Jean.
Oh my god.
I know I'm not gonna get...
That's also the thing.
Um...
Jean.
Because I can feel...
They're...
I...
They're all just gonna...
Take it.
I...
Take your hero.
Or villain.
I'm so faster.
Let's go.
Um...
Wait, wait, wait.
Hello.
I'm so...
Is...
Does Doki have a mic?
Goddammit!
Bro, I just wanna play one game.
I...
Then I'm out.
I'm like...
So done.
I'm...
I still have...
Bro, I still have...
Bro, I'm just...
I'm just doing one game.
Wait, can Doki at least hear me?
I wanna...
I wanna do the...
Did everyone miss me while I was off soaring through the stars?
Yo, Mina.
Can you hear me?
I'm...
She doesn't.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
Alright, here we go.
I'm...
I'm out after this.
I just want...
I'm just...
I'm out after this.
I'm...
I'm done.
I...
You like my new skin.
This is it.
This is sucking it.
Alright.
Yeah.
I told...
I told you.
I'm...
I can't...
I don't like custom lobbies because of it.
Because they like...
People try too hard.
I'm just cringled right there.
And they all want you to talk.
And I was like, I don't wanna attack!
I just want a pit.
Uh oh.
Oh, I just went into the chair.
Nice.
Alright.
Okay, wait, who's that?
It looks like the mission area is yours to capture now.
Oh, unlucky.
Wait, where's our support?
Okay.
I was gonna say... Oh, our mantis... Oh, our invis woman died.
I don't want to socialize.
I just want to play.
I don't even socialize in rank.
How do you expect me to socialize in a fucking play?
Okay.
Also, these players are actually good.
I recognize, like, one of them.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I actually have to think, too.
This sucks.
Oh.
Oh, you can dodge.
Okay, this guy actually plays Star-Lord.
What is this?
Are you serious?
She dodged it?
Oh my god.
This guy actually plays Star-Lord.
This sucks.
Guys, I'm just a support player.
I'm literally just a... Fuck this.
Hello, I'm safe.
I'm safe now.
Hello.
Oh my god.
Please.
You can't catch me.
You see that?
Turning up the heat.
Oh.
These guys actually play DPS.
This fucking sucks.
Okay, I got trapped.
Wait, it's a 5v... Oh my god.
It was... It was a 5v6 anyway.
Guys, I told you.
This is why I didn't want to touch Custom Lobby.
This is exactly...
This is exactly why.
Hello.
I'm gonna die to this.
I'm pretty sure.
Oh, we're fucking dead.
I don't think we have.
Oh my god.
Oh my...
Hello.
I'll play around this.
Alright.
I lived.
I lived somehow.
See?
Holy shit.
I'm just aim training at this point.
I lived.
If we stay focused, we've got this.
I hate this map.
Bro, someone left like...
While we were play- like in the middle of this.
Before you attack.
Get ready.
I lived.
There's the- who's the host?
That was a long time ago.
Now, I'm just Mantis.
Oh!
Did he wanted Gina and then left?
This guy is- Alright.
That's good enough.
That's- That's- That's- Oh my god.
I'm stuck too.
That's good enough.
That's- That's enough.
We got our game.
We- We got our game.
I'm- I'm good.
I-
We got- We got our game.
Guys, this is exactly why I don't do custom lobbies.
It's just- It's too scuffed.
I- I'm just like normal randoms.
I- I got my game.
I- It's always so fun to socialize, guys.
See, if you go in quick match, I don't have to have the oblig- Like, it's just like, you know, I feel less guilty.
Not talking.
But people just wanna talk in custom lobbies.
And I'm like, bro, I just wanna- And then- And then like, when you don't- And then when people don't get Jean.
Um, when people don't get Jean, they leave.
And there's no way to backfill too.
So that's the worst part.
There's no like, backfilling.
Uh- Guy r- Ragequid cuz Doki has the better system.
Like, oh, I'm sorry.
We're all content creators here.
Like, I- I just- Happen to have the better fucking system.
I'm sorry.
I just- Maybe like, QA quick match.
She'll like, put me in while I rant.
Who knows?
We'll- we'll test it out.
Scout, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you- thank you.
Fun fact.
The image of Wolverine looking at Polaroid.
That Jean comes from the Phoenix arc.
When he thinks she's dead from Sinestro.
At least that's what the 90's X-Men cartoon taught me.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, but yeah.
But, you know what?
I got a chance to like, try out Jean.
I think like, I think it was just 5v6.
Like, we weren't winning that.
It was just unlucky on my end.
Um, it was like, just five- Yeah, like, I just stole Phoenix.
So then we didn't get an actual round.
And then, the Starlight player was an actual DPS player.
I could tell from- he was an actual Star-Lord.
Like, one- like, I could- I don't want to say one trick.
But I can tell that he was an actual Star-Lord player.
Just because of his like, of the- yeah.
He knew how to dodge.
He had like, the dodges correctly.
Where he can basically dodge like, you know, with any ability.
And all- with just this like, dodge movement.
Um, so, he knew how to play.
And I was like, like, that's- I just- I knew.
I was like, fuck it, whatever.
But, anyway.
I'm gonna call that- I'm gonna call that here.
Because we have another stream later today, anyway.
Um, I don't think we're gonna grab- get another game in.
And like, I really don't want to deal with custom lobbies.
Because like, people are just- Everyone wants to play Jean!
And there's no backfill!
So like, there's no- it's just not fun.
Um, anyway guys.
I think in the future, when I do these early access, I'm definitely gonna- Um, I'm definitely gonna try and like, just queue up the games right off the bat.
Just cause like, I feel like- I feel like, you know, all the players got- already got all the content they needed.
And like, there's not enough players in the quick match rotation right now.
Um, and everybody's just doing custom lobbies with their friends or other content creators.
Which makes sense, but like, um- But like, I just- I'm just tired.
Anyways, I hope you guys have fun checking out the new season.
As always everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
If you stay up for me, stay up a little longer.
Cause I have a- Uh, special announcement.
Um, later today.
Uh, for the birthday countdown.
So yes, uh, stay up a little longer for that.
I'm gonna take a fucking nap.
I'm so tired.
Uh, I know I keep saying that, but- I am very exhausted.
Uh, cool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Why does squirrel girl look like that?
Uh-huh.
Oh yeah, you guys want- Oh, this is- This is her- Her- Oh my god!
Bro!
It takes up the entire screen!
Like, you don't even see her anymore.
This is her charm point.
Right?
Hey guys, as always everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
Stay up for me.
Stay up a little longer for tonight's stream.
Anyway guys, I'll see you guys later everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!